is there an idea that maybe is a little
bit smaller
that you find beautiful in the space of
mathematics or physics
there's an idea that you know i kind of
went got a physics phd and spent a lot
of time learning about mathematics and i
guess
it was embarrassing and i hadn't really
actually understood this very simple
idea
um until and kind of learned it when i
actually started teaching math classes
which is
maybe that there there maybe
there's a simple way to explain kind of
the fundamental way in which algebra and
geometry are connected so you normally
think of geometry is about these spaces
and these points and
and you think of algebra is this very
abstract thing about with these
abstract objects that satisfy certain
kinds of relations you can multiply them
and add them and
do stuff but it's it's completely
abstract and there's nothing geometric
about it but the um
the kind of really
fundamental idea is that unifies algebra
and geometry is to is to realize is to
think when whenever anybody gives you
what you call an algebra some abstract
thing of things that you can multiply
and add
that you should ask yourself
is that algebra the space of functions
on some geometry
so one of the most surprising examples
of this for instance is a
i mean a standard kind of
thing that seems to have nothing to do
with geometry is the um
is the the integer so then they're you
can you can multiply them and add them
it's
it's an algebra but the um
it has seems to have nothing to do with
geometry but what you can it turns out
but if you ask yourself this question
and ask you know is
are integers can you think if somebody
gives you an integer can you think of it
as a function on some space
on some geometry and it turns out that
yes you can and the space is the space
of prime numbers
and so what you do is you just if
somebody gives you an integer
you can make a function on the prime
numbers by just
you know at each prime number taking
that
that integer modulo that prime so if if
you say i don't know if you get given 10
you know 10 and you ask what is its
value at 2 well it's
it's 5 times 2 so mod 2 it's 0. so it
takes 0 1. what what is
what is this value at three
well it's nine plus one so it's it's one
mod three so it's about it's zero at two
it's one at three and you can kind of
keep going
and so
this is really kind of a
truly fundamental idea it's at the basis
of what's called algebraic geometry and
it just links these two parts of
mathematics that look completely
different and it's just an incredibly
powerful idea and so much of mathematics
emerges from this kind of
simple relation so uh you're talking
about mapping from one discrete space to
another to another so
um
for a second i thought perhaps uh
mapping like a continuous space of
discrete space like functions over a
continuous space
uh
because yeah well you can i mean you can
take if somebody gives you a space
you can ask you can say well let's let's
and this is also this is part of the
same idea the part of the same idea is
that if you try and do geometry and
somebody tells you here's a space
that what you should do is you said wait
so say wait wait a minute maybe i should
be trying to solve this using algebra
and so if i do that the way to start is
you give me the space i start to think
about the functions of the space
okay so for to each point in the space i
associate
a number i can take different kinds of
functions and different kinds of values
but but basically functions on a space
so
what this
insight is telling you is that if you're
a geometer often the way to
to to work is to trans change your
problem into algebra by changing your
space stop thinking about your space and
the points in it and think about the
functions on it got it and if you're if
you're an algebraic and you've got these
abstract algebraic gadgets that you're
multiplying and adding say wait a minute
are those gadgets
can i think of them in some way as a
function on a space what would that
space be and what kind of functions
would they be and that
going back and forth really brings these
two completely different looking areas
of mathematics together do you have uh
particular examples where it allowed to
prove some difficult things by jumping
from one to the other is that something
that's a part of modern mathematics
where such jumps are made oh yes this is
kind of all the time a lot much much of
modern number theory is kind of based on
this idea but
and and when you start doing this you
start to realize that you need
you know what simple
things simple things on one side the
algebras start to require you to think
about
the other side about geometry in a new
way you have to kind of get a more
sophisticated idea about geometry or if
you
start thinking about the functions on a
space
you may have you may need a more
sophisticated kind of algebra but um but
in some sense i mean much or most of
modern number theory is
based upon this move to geometry and um
there's also a lot of geometry and
topology is also based upon
yeah changing if you want to understand
the topology of something you look at
the functions you do durham homology and
you get the topology
anyway
well let me let me ask you then the
ridiculous question you said that this
idea is beautiful
uh can you formalize the definition of
the word beautiful and why is this
beautiful like first why is this
beautiful and second
um
what is beautiful yeah well
and i think there are many different
things you can find beautiful for
different reasons i mean i think in this
context
the notion of beauty i think really is
just kind of
an idea is beautiful if it's
packages a huge amount of kind of
power and information into
something very simple so in some sense
you i mean
you can almost kind of try and measure
it in the sense of you know what's the
what are the implications of this idea
what non-trivial things does it tell you
versus
you know how how how how simply can you
can you express the idea and so so level
of compression yeah uh what is it
correlates with uh beauty yeah that's
that's one and one aspect of it and so
you can start to tell that an idea is
becoming uglier and uglier
as you start kind of having to
you know it doesn't quite do what you
want so you throw in something else to
the idea and you keep doing that until
you get what you want but that's how you
know you're doing something uglier and
uglier when you have to kind of keep
adding in
more
more into what was originally a fairly
simple idea and making it more and more
complicated to get what you want
okay so let's put some philosophical
words on the table and try to make some
sense of them one word is beauty another
one is simplicity as you mentioned
another one is truth
so
do you have a sense if i give you two
theories one is
simpler one is more complicated
do you have a sense which one is more
likely to be true
to uh
capture
deeply
the fabric of reality
the simple one or the more complicated
one i yeah i think all of our evidence
what we see in the history of the
subject is the the simpler one though
often it's
a surprise it's simpler in a surprising
way but um
yeah that we just don't we just
anyway when the kind of best theories
have been coming coming up with are
ultimately when properly understood
relatively simple and uh much much
simpler than you would expect them to be
do you have a good explanation why that
is is it just because humans want it to
be that way are we just like ultra
biased then we we we just kind of
convinced ourselves
that simple is better because we find
simplicity beautiful or is there
something about at the our actual
universe
that uh at the core is simple
my own belief is that there is something
about a universe that that's simple and
i was trying to say that you know there
is some some kind of fundamental thing
about math physics
and physics and all this picture which
is um
which which is in some sense simple
it's true that you know it
it's of course true that you know our
minds have certain have
are very limited and can certainly do
certain things and not others so it
it's it's in principle possible that
there's some
great insight there's a lot of insights
into the way the world works which is
aren't accessible to us because that's
not the way our minds work we don't and
that what we're seeing this kind of
simplicity is just because that's
all we ever have any hope of seeing
you